se ha convertido en el primer rostro de
los presuntos crímenes de guerra rusos
vadim sí sí marín de 21 años está
acusado de matar a un hombre desarmado
de 62 en la región de schumi al noreste
del país en febrero apenas unos días
después de que comenzara la invasión él
y otros cuatro soldados supuestamente
robaron un vehículo y estaban huyendo
cuando se encontraron con el hombre y lo
mataron para evitar ser denunciados la
fiscal superior de ucrania dice que el
juicio que tiene lugar en medio del
conflicto en curso pretende entregar un
mensaje con este primer juicio estamos
enviando una señal clara de que todos
los autores todas las personas que
ordenaron o ayudaron a cometer crímenes
en ucrania no podrán evitar su
responsabilidad también están en marcha
varias investigaciones internacionales
con la participación de la onu y la
corte penal internacional
muchas se centran en el suburbio de
busca en kiev donde se encontraron los
cadáveres de cientos de civiles tras la
retirada de las tropas rusas a
principios de abril mientras tanto los
fiscales ucranianos avanzan en la
investigación de más de 11.000 casos y
se espera que otros dos
se desarrollan rápidamente un soldado
ruso será juzgado en ausencia por
violación y asesinato mientras que el
juicio contra dos soldados acusados de
disparar cohetes contra civiles en la
región nororiental de jarquín comenzará
el jueves